[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens les transports en
commun parisiens elles sont très
pratiques pas toujours à l'heure donc
c'est pas très bon pas très propre la
ratp aussi nos utilisateurs pour
améliorer tout ça ça c'est vrai que
parfois c'est impeut c'est un peu crade
il en pense quoi
mon frère à elle doit bien le vivre
c'est un gros bonjour monsieur
c'est tellement beau l'amour tellement
possible ravisseur des aussi d'ailleurs
fait tomber des tripes et à daniel lévy
qu'est ce que je pense des transports
parisiens
qu'est ce qu'elle en pense votre soeur
en à votre sort tu prenne le relais
voire fait qu'ils nous emmerdent toi tu
nous laisses de secondes discuter oh je
te jure je vais t'arracher coup je fais
chier dans deux voitures n'ont pas levé
réveiller c'est trop cher je vote sort
alors bon choix pour ça donc on sort de
chez fabio salsa tie and dye 30 daphné
bürki tie and dye nos cimade grandes
structures
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens mais je trouve
qu'ils sont pas mal du loing
si tokyo ne pas trop serrer et sinon je
vais vous dire j'ai petit de fixation
l'erreur rpp thoracique des sièges qui
sont crades grade crade
on a le sentiment que quelqu'un vient de
celle sur laquelle non merci ça votre
plus les villes c'est pour la pub c'est
une force
oui c'est votre or c'est mon grand père
voyait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]